here's a couple things that Trump has
been doing uh and you tell me if you if
you if this feels right to you if you
think this is going to work and just
pointing out once again we don't even
know if DeSantis is going to run and
this is extremely early so it seems like
you're throwing the kitchen sink out at
this point here's uh here's Trump on
Truth social apparently some random
person dong Chang Lee uh found on Truth
social found this picture we're told
that apparently this is Ron DeSantis at
some point I don't know and it says here
is Ron de sanctimonious worst nickname
ever it's not sticking grooming high
school girls with alcohol as a teacher
okay first off it's not clear if that's
doctored or not secondly
um it could be non-alcoholic beer it
could be root beer we don't know what
the hell it is there's no none of these
girls like it's even to me talking about
this in some ways I'm doing Trump's
dirty work here which I don't like but
the point is does anyone think that
that's really a rep a good
representation of the life that Ron
DeSantis is living and did did all of us
do crazy things in college and all of
that stuff but he's doing that kind of
thing and
and what oh so just put it up one more
time so what he what Trump added to it
was that's not Ron is it he would never
do such a thing I mean this is Donald
Trump grab him by the so it's like
is this the game you want to play man is
this the game you want to play so
DeSantis is wisely just playing this
thing real cool take a look
and I'd also just say this
I spend my time delivering results for
the people of Florida and fighting
against Joe Biden that's how I spend my
time
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't spend my time trying to smear
other Republicans
yeah that's the right answer that's the
right I'm here to do a job and I'm doing
that job and I'm doing it better than
anybody and you back to me and you live
in my state and I don't think anyone
wants that crap one of the things that's
interesting and Trump has done a few of
these types of messages
I'm actually sort of sorry I've been
showed it because it Butterfly Effects
the thing and it's just nonsense it's
not going anywhere okay fine
um but Trump if you're willing to take
out the guy who probably is the best guy
we've got then are you really America
First at that point that's the question
[Music]
foreign